ED LU: If you find something that's going to
hit the earth, deflecting it is actually
relatively easy. Because if you find it
many years before it hits the earth, say
10, 20 years before it hits the earth—
remember, the earth is going to go around
the Sun 10 or 20 times, as will that
object. So these things have a long ways
to travel before they hit, and that means
a tiny, tiny, tiny change in
their orbit will keep something from
hitting the earth. ZANDER ROSE: You just slow the
earth down a little bit. LU: Yes. ROSE: There's a great new Chinese movie coming out about this.
LU: But, for those of you who took
physics, if we all jump at the same time, we
don't change the velocity of the earth,
because we're connected to it. Right? You
need an external momentum. So what you actually do — ROSE: That's a boring answer.
LU: Yeah, the boring answer is to change the
orbits of the asteroid by a tiny amount.
And one of the things that we had been
urging since the foundation of our, the
B612 Foundation, is that we human beings
ought to test that technology because we
know how to do it. And in fact, NASA is
now going to do that test. It's
called the DART mission, again, about 2022
I believe it is. We're just going to
actually run a small spacecraft into an
asteroid. And that is actually
sufficient in the mass majority of cases to
keep an asteroid from hitting the earth —
provided you have notice. Now back to your
question. Predicting that
something is going to hit requires you
be able to calculate
orbits very, very accurately, and know the
uncertainties in order to calculate what are the chances that this
thing hits. And I don't want to give the
impression that we're the only ones
doing it. There are other people that think
of, they calculate these things
and they put these things in big tables. Okay, but think of what the difference is
between Google Maps, and if somebody
listed for you every restaurant in New
York City in a big table. What's the
difference? And why is, why was Google
Maps so important to commerce, to
things like Lyft and Uber? They all
started by using Google Maps. Yelp. Airbnb.
Because they didn't, the visual
mapping part, the underlying machinery
was built for them and they could just
build on top of it. And so what we want
to do is allow people to build
navigation tools for the solar system
without having to do all the heavy
lifting.
99.99% of the calculation is exactly the
same. It can happen in the background. And
so we want to provide that as a service.